le 16 septembre la 36e édition de
l'Estival et de retour à Poissy cette
année le festival musical revient avec
de nombreux artistes Kenny le bagous
bonjour vous êtes le responsable
production de l'Estival merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors j'imagine
que vous attendez le lancement de cette
36e édition avec impatience l'heure elle
est encore au préparatifs aujourd'hui
l'heure et Léo préparatifs puisque le
festival commence dans quelques jours
avec le premier concert aura lieu dans
cette salle au théâtre de Poissy
l'occasion des Journées européennes du
patrimoine on est dans la dernière ligne
droite et justement qu'est-ce que vous
avez prévu pour ce premier week-end avec
les journées du patrimoine et ben en
fait on va proposer un spectacle très
belles original par sa forme et son
contenu qui est le Béaba de la chanson
c'est un spectacle mené par Jules un
artiste du 95 donc pas très loin d'ici
qui a invité plein d'autres gens mais
les semelles ou Ali et ils vont
revisiter en fait le la chanson
française sous forme d'un ABC d'un genre
ils vont s'attaquer aux lettres CDEF
donc ça va être de Cabrel à Céline Dion
en passant par Calogero à leur façon
c'est très drôle c'est un peu déjanté et
ça colle bien avec cette idée de
patrimoine et de la chanson et des
Journées européennes du patrimoine et
justement la chanson elle est au cœur de
l'Estival depuis 1988 l'Estival c'est
imposé dans les Yvelines comme un
festival de référence en quoi ce
festival il est important aujourd'hui
encore dans les Yvelines festival il est
important parce que il a une ligne
éditoriale assez singulière en
Île-de-France qui est la défense de la
chanson francophone et pas forcément
française mais francophone dans sous
toutes ses formes et on accueille des
artistes
aux origines venues d'Afrique du Canada
de Suisse Belgique
la Franc la chanson française c'est pas
que la France c'est aussi la
francophonie dans toute sa diversité de
style musical aussi on a des fois
tendance à penser que la chanson c'est
un piano voit une guitare voix et ben
pas forcément ça peut prendre plein de
formes on accueille cette année Suzanne
avec sa chance c'est de la chanson
électro ou de sagaçant c'est des
nouvelles formes de chansons à texte
avec des textes très beaux très forts
mais l'enrobage musical autour et
moderne et c'est aussi ça la chanson
actuelle et justement alors vous avez
commencé à nous parler de certains des
artistes la grande force de l'Estival
c'est également d'avoir des grandes voix
mais aussi des artistes émergents ce que
vous pouvez nous donner quelques noms de
ces artistes qu'on connaît déjà et qu'on
va découvrir oui l'idée de l'Estival a
toujours été de programmer des premières
parties ce qui permet au public de
découvrir de jeunes talents ou de
nouveaux talons alors en effet cette
année on va voir la chance d'accueillir
Camille Lellouche ici même
Chimène Badi
mais aussi à haute sagaçant au sac à HR
qui est quand même l'étoile montante de
la chanson depuis quelques mois on a une
très belle soirée avec Suzanne au forum
Armand Peugeot à Poissy autour de la
chanson électro on a on a aussi les
spectacle qui nous tient vraiment à cœur
qui sont les vitrines découvertes c'est
un plateau de 6 artistes qui vont
proposer et montrer leur univers leur
talent un panel de directeurs festival
de directeur de salles c'est aussi un de
ça un des engagements de l'Estival sur
la chanson et justement Kenny je vous
propose qu'on écoute quelques extraits
de ces artistes qu'on découvrira à
l'Estival
[Musique]
j'ai ouvert tous mes chakras les signes
je les reçois je fais là pour aller dans
il fait toujours beau au-dessus des
nuages mais moi si j'étais un oiseau
j'irai danser sous l'orage cette année
c'est une saison particulière c'est la
première saison sans Mark Pfeiffer qui
est à l'origine de l'Estival pourquoi
c'était important de continuer et de lui
rendre hommage également en effet
disparu en tout début d'année il a créé
ce festival il y a 36 ans avec une bande
d'amis
on est tous persuadés que c'est ce qu'il
aurait voulu que l'Estival continue
malgré son absence tout en gardant les
fondamentaux qu'il a toujours voulu
défendre la défense des artistes du
spectacle et donc c'était important de
continuer ce qu'il avait ce qu'il a
amorcé il y a presque 40 ans
et surtout le concert d'ouverture donc
avec le bas de la chanson c'est un
concert mené par Jules qui a un artiste
que marque aimait beaucoup connaissait
bien ça fait des années qu'on le
soutient et qu'on suit son travail il a
été comme nous tous très affecté par sa
disparition donc c'est aussi une manière
de rejoindre les ponts vous nous parlez
des grandes valeurs de ce festival parmi
les grandes valeurs il y a la valeur
associative cette année est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un petit peu de la
grande cause que vous allez soutenir
donc cette année on soutient le gemme
des lumières qui est une association
d'accueil de jeunes adultes
ça leur permet de trouver un lien social
de retrouver surtout un lien social un
lien
affectif pour certains mais aussi des
valeurs de sortie d'entraide pour des
gens qui sont renfermés qui se sont
renfermés dans la dépression ou dans
d'autres problèmes de ce type là comme
tous les ans tous les bénéfices du bar
des produits de vente dérivés iront
intégralement à cette association alors
Kenny le bagous nous sommes au théâtre
de Poissy qui va accueillir de nombreux
artistes quels sont les autres villes
dans lesquelles vont s'implanter le
l'Estival cette année donc cette année
nous aurons des spectacles dans cinq
villes des Yvelines où ils montaient son
le PEC évidemment Poissy et HR par
exemple à HR on va proposer donc les
vitrines découvertes à haute-sagaçant
mais aussi à l'occasion de la fête du
céleri un spectacle puisque c'est même
pas un concert c'est un specte c'est un
vrai spectacle de rue gratuit ouvert à
tous à l'occasion de la fête du céleri
avec les frères jacquard c'est un
spectacle musical humoristique c'est
très drôle c'est pour toute la famille
le 30 septembre et justement c'est une
nouveauté de l'Estival de s'implanter un
petit peu plus dans les événements
locaux pourquoi vous avez décidé de
changer un petit peu la forme d'évoluer
aussi oui c'est aussi une façon de
trouver du lien avec les différentes
communes les différents publics donc on
s'est inséré comme vous dites à la fête
du céleri à Achères mais aussi à la fête
de l'air à Montesson qui sont des
événements attendus par les populations
et nous on vient apporter notre
expertise sur la musique ou sur la
programmation d'artistes ça nous permet
ça permet aussi à ces événements de
grandir un peu mais aussi de faire
découvrir de la musique gratuitement
puisque tous ces événements sont
gratuits d'autres manières que d'être
dans un théâtre ou dans une salle de
spectacle l'autre force de l'Estival
c'est de proposer des artistes très
différents il y en aura pour tous les
goûts cette année
j'espère on a essayé de faire une
programmation la plus éclectique
possible ça va de la grande chanson
française avec Chimène Badi qui chante
Piaf Louis Chedid Yvan Cassard qui sont
des artistes qu'on présente plus depuis
bien longtemps mais aussi la jeune
génération avec Suzanne doutes saga 100
ou bien Camille Lellouche mais aussi du
slam au théâtre blanche de casting une
soirée folle que au club Peggy mené par
Étienne Fletcher ou à Houilles une
soirée plus chanson rock avec cancre
sueur c'est aussi des artistes de la
nouvelle génération pour ceux qui n'ont
pas encore pris leur place pourquoi il
faut venir à l'Estival cette année pour
passer un bon moment écoutez de la belle
musique et bien ce sera le mot de la fin
merci Kenny le bacous d'avoir répondu à
nos questions alors l'Estival c'est du
16 septembre au 7 octobre on vous
souhaite un bon festival et on vous
souhaite une très belle soirée sur TV 78